all right y'all let's dip into the world
of social media Before We Say Goodbye
this is what I'm
liking a woman in Southern California
woke up to her dog barking and
scratching at the floor she looked
outside and noticed the cover to her
crawl space ripped off uh when she went
to investigate she discovered
this it's a bear a several hundred pound
black bear just chilling under her
floorboards hanging out most of us would
freak out uh but not this lady she
managed to get the bear out on her own
how did she do it let's find out for
anyone else who this happens to uh we
have Tina on the line who watches on NBC
Los Angeles what's up Tina hi Kelly
hello what did you do when you found out
it was a bear I was so nervous when I
saw those eyes staring back at me you
know I live in a small suburb of Los
Angeles County called Monrovia we get
Bears all the time so I went back to bed
thinking no big deal but when my dog
Archie went nuts I thought is that bear
underneath my house when I saw the crawl
space grate ripped off its hinges I'm
like oh no it's down there so I walked
down to my basement with my flashlight
and I eyes Shone right back at me I
thought oh no what did you do well I
Googled how to get a bear out of crawl
space nothing came
up nothing came up so I thought why I
have to take it this in my own hands so
I turned my heat on real high made a
bunch of noise I got some pots and pans
and started banging them it didn't budge
I got my leaf blower I went down there
aimed it at him it didn't budge it was
just laying there looking at me blinking
at me with those cute eyes oh my God God
bless
Google how did you finally get the bear
out well I reached out to our mayor who
had the police come by and they had a
public safety officer who knew about
Bears um and he told me get some mock
balls and throw it up in your crawl
space so I did and it did the trip they
don't like the smell of mck balls and
that bear left I didn't want a bear
sleepover yeah that's a that's a big
black bear he is full yeah he he's not
skinny um well thank you so much Tina
this is hilarious and I'm liking your
post right now I'm glad everything's
okay that picture man come on our season
long partner pilot pin makers of precise
the goto pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
love your story as much as we do so
they're going to be riding you a check
for $1,000 so maybe invest in some more
moth
balls all right thank you Tina stay safe
and thank you to all our guests this
hour Katherine Newton Co sprous Zelda
Williams Diablo Cody Sarah J mass and
the cast of Kimber a Kimbo youall have a
great vein if it's not change
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home